In this video we shall be reviewing the best practice guidance for recording login sequences
in BurpSuite Enterprise Edition. This feature is used to log into sites with complex login
mechanisms. Whilst the BurpSuite Navigation Recorder Chrome extension is easy to use in
of itself, successfully recording a login sequence for a sophisticated authentication mechanism can
be a complex process. This documentation is designed to give advice that should help when
recording your login sequences. To begin it's worth reviewing the limitations of the recorded
login sequence. Whilst they are intended to handle a wide variety of login mechanisms,
they do have some limitations. Firstly, recorded logins are only compatible with browser-powered
scans. If BurpSuite cannot initialize its browser, then the scan cannot start. Additionally,
BurpSuite cannot self-register users or deliberately trigger login failures by submitting invalid credentials
as part of a login sequence. As a result, any login functions crawl settings from your scan configuration.
BurpSuite will be a copy of the login sequence. If BurpSuite will be a copy of the login sequence,
BurpSuite will be a copy of the login sequence. If BurpSuite will be a copy of the login sequence.
BurpSuite will be a copy of the login sequence.